allez on va démarrer par laurence ça y
est qui dit non il n'est pas chaud qui
lance absolument pas parce que c'est
normal qu'il s'amuse un petit peu quand
même
en plus il a quand même plutôt bossé
pendant les vacances c'est rare que je
le défends bien sûr mais heureusement
qu'il est là des loisirs heureusement
qu'ils s'éclatent et il avait pas
prendre une barque avec des rames
je pense que la corvée le jet ski parce
que c'est dieu qui s'est un petit peu
choqué pas dans les écologistes c'est
complètement absurde j'aimerais bien
savoir ce qu'ils ont fait leurs vacances
mais bon on a l'habitude et pourquoi pas
du jet ski
enfin il est jeune il est beau en plus
je trouve qu'on voit qu'il a la pêche
on préfère non surtout que d'avoir
quelqu'un d'habitué sur une barque sur
un lac
voyez ça va peut-être pire qu'en images
d'accord jours parce qu'une valeur
élagage foulon c'est vrai gaspard oui
alors moi que ça m'a choqué pour deux
raisons à la fois parce que j'en ai
marre de cette peopolisation de la vie
politique n'est pas nouvelle
que la presse c'est une presse
particulière pour suivre le président
les hommes politiques pour essayer de
prendre des photos volées des photos ça
me fatigue et d'autre part parce que je
pense que le prix aura république quel
qu'il soit et c'est arrivé souvent
malheureusement à françois hollande doit
faire très attention à sa propre image
et éviter de se retrouver dans ce genre
de situation vous vous êtes si vous avez
est-il conseillé de ma d'emmanuel macron
là après vous l'appelez après sa boule
élites je crois que j'ai cru vous alliez
me dire que vous aussi vous aviez été
conseiller de françois hollande est ce
que vous lui auriez conseillé de faire
du jet ski
j'aurais répondu non récurrents scooter
scooter effectifs industriels histoire
du scooter comment on gère parce que je
vous rappeler tous bien sûr des
histoires du scooter en une de closer
on voit donc françois hollande a mené
des croissants à julie gayet qu'est-ce
que vous l'avez dit après alors moi
j'étais pas encore arrivé quand c'est
arrivé mais en fait subir les suite de
cela parce qu'en fait on n'a parlé que
de ça pendant deux ans parce que l'image
du clan de la république avait été
durement touchée en fait par cet
événement on se moquait de lui a vu la
cravate de travail puis après y aller ça
mais françois on avait quand même
conservé le sens de l'humour parce que
le jour où j'ai été recruté à l'elysée
quelques semaines après cet incident
justement j'arrivais moi même je suis du
scooter dont je me balade dans la cour
de l'elysée avec une cascade à la main
etc
je manque de me péter la gueule dont le
haut des escaliers et là françois
hollande regarde même dit à gaspard vous
êtes le nouveau très important de
scooter pour réussir l'année il a
beaucoup d'humour beaucoup d'humour mais
malheureusement cette image lui a fait
du mal je pense que l'image emmanuel
macron n'est pas exactement la même
parce que si une image de loisy
2 2 elle dégage de la puissance mais
emmanuel macron pendant la campagne
présidentielle avait beaucoup dit qu'un
prix dans la république ne devait pas
être comme les autres justement pas
normal et pas forcément prendre des
vacances comme les autres noms s'est
adjugé 2 ce qui est je pense que c'était
une bonne vision des choses je pense
qu'ils font une forme de sacralité dans
l'exercice du pouvoir qui passent pas
nécessairement parce qu'aujourd'hui
alors petite question parce que là vous
vous lui auriez dit quoi vous l'auriez
dites-moi emmanuel macron là vous êtes a
fait une bêtise
on aurait pu s'en passer ou bien cela
soit la partie moment où ces faits
appartement - s est fait il faut plutôt
organiser chercher à le relativiser
parce que c'est pas non plus très grave
non mais ça après il ya une autre
question qui se pose pour tous les
prendre la république c'est que
appartement quelqu'un peut le prendre en
photo lui ça pose des questions de
sécurité oci pas question que vous me
posez parce que les téléspectateurs
doivent se dire la même chose
imaginons que le mec à la place d'un
appareil photo et ses soins snipers mine
de rien là c'est pour la sécurité du
réseau
le risque zéro n'existe pas pour
quiconque et même pour le prendre à un
public même si un service particulier
s'appelle groupement de sécurité la
présence de la république au autour de
lui il ya près je sais pas dans cette
situation s'il était véritablement en
danger et peut-être qu'autour de lui
avait beaucoup de militaires extérieures
imprimés l'attrait que beaucoup de
militaires si vous arrivez à le shooter
comme ça avec un appareil il ya des
zooms mais c'est pas beau les la photo
elle est organisée la photo avec
justement je sais pas photo alors que ça
sert mais moi plutôt que choquer je suis
consterné parce qu on a pu reprocher à
emmanuel macron au début de son mandat
un excès de verticalité maintenant c'est
un excès d'horizontalité puisque ils
postent des photos de ses vacances comme
le premier clan pas venu c'est qui qui
vous impose ses photos de vacances quand
quand vous le voyez en septembre moi je
ne crois absolument pas que ce soit des
photos volées je ne bois pas quelqu'un
qui puisse s'approcher du président de
la république surtout dans ce cadre
assez près pour faire ce genre de photos
c'est juste la poursuite de la
peopolisation de la vie politique ça a
commencé dans les années 60 et ça n'a
plus de limites
je pense que nommer le président de la
république
emmanuel macron je pense qu'ils les
décors assez intelligent vous pensez
vraiment qu'il va faire en sorte de se
faire prendre en photo oui comme ça moi
je moi je crois que s'est posée je crois
que c'est organisé et moi j'attends de
celui qui détient le pouvoir suprême
un peu de distance avec nous un peu de
solennité là il ya plus du tout de
solennité
c'est aussi ce que fait poutine qui aime
bien s'exhibe c'est ça ouais s'exhibait
torse luce a commencé dans les années 60
avec kennedy ligne aura plus de
limitez moi je pense qu'il faut qu'il y
ait une limite qui ait une séparation
entre celui qui devinera center des
mères aussi un bien sûr non mais tout on
a eu le cheval le scoop à leur terre
c'est à dire que la ligne c'est à dire
qu'on a le droit de vivre quand on fait
de la politique il me semble voilà
pourquoi on devrait pas faire du scooter
des mers de vivre comme les autres mais
quand la paranoïa rien fait d'interdît
il a rien fait il faut une verticalité
quand même il faut garder un peu de
verticalité un président de la
république je regrette ce n'est pas un
français comme les autres il ne vit pas
comme nous il n'a pas les mêmes
responsabilités
on n'a pas à voir ses photos de vacances
qu'est ce que qu'est ce que ça apporte à
parrot on voit qu'il est enfin l'origine
était presque alors jacques chirac s'est
fait prendre en photo tout nu à
brégançon il ya quelques années vous
souvenez de cette anecdote c'est vrai
mais là c'était pas c'était pas organisé
je n'espère pas c'était bernadac il
offre un coût
m